PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Deconstructing Chatbots.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we will learn how to integrate
Dialogflow agent with ML APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Depending on what your
conversational AI use case is,
your users may want to upload an
image to the chat application,
and expect a response
that guides them further
in that conversation.
This is exactly what
we will learn today.
We will be seeing how to
create a Dialogflow agent that
fulfills an image request by
calling the Google Vision API.
We will be using the same Django
front-end application that we
created in the previous
episode and add image upload
functionality to it.
If you've not watched
the previous episode,
I highly recommend
you start there.
All right.
So here's what we are building.
The user ends up on
our chat application
and interacts with it.
The chatbot responds
with a greeting defining
the two things it can do--
setting up appointments
and understanding invoices.
We've already seen
setting up appointments
in the previous episodes, so
we'll just skip that for now
and just ask for
understanding our bill.
User is prompted to upload
the image of their invoice.
Once they upload that image,
we display it on our front-end
and return back the text
detected in that image
by processing it
through the Vision API.
Now, from architectural
standpoint,
here's how this is working.
The chat app will be
served on App Engine.
The app is built in
Python using Django,
which is a Python-based free
and open source web framework.
App Engine will interact with
Cloud SQL for any database
requests.
When users upload the
files, we will save them
to Google Cloud Storage.
And the app will interact
with our Dialogflow
agent via the Dialogflow API.
The example uses the
appointment scheduler
that we created in
the third episode,
and enhanced in
the eighth episode,
to integrate with
Google Calendar.
Today, we are
enhancing it further
by adding an integration
with Vision API.
Now, with that background,
let's dive in and
see how to make it work.
Check out the link in
the description below
to download the source
code for this application.
Make sure to follow
the setup steps.
I'm going to show you
the main part that
makes the integration with
the Vision API possible.
But you can read the
elaborate setup instructions
in the readme file.
First, let's look at
the Dialogflow console.
I'm still using the previously
created appointment scheduler
agent from episode three.
We will start from
the welcome intent.
Modify the response so
that the users clearly
know that our chatbot can
handle appointment scheduling
and invoice-related questions.
Next, create an
intent to capture
users' input if they
are contacting us
about their invoice.
Provide a static
response telling the user
to upload a file.
Create an intent that
takes the file input.
Once the user has
provided the file,
we extract the file name
using a custom entity.
If you don't know what
custom entities are,
check out episode six.
And for the response,
enable the fulfillment.
Check out the
front-end Django code
to see how to handle the
plumbing from front-end
to Dialogflow.
Now, let's see the
fulfillment.js file.
Scroll down to the
intent map section,
and define the new intent
map for file upload.
In the function
applyML pass the agent
and declare a variable to
get hold of the file name
that the user has uploaded.
We can do that by writing
agent.parameters.filename.
Then call a function to
handle Vision API request.
You pass the bucket
name and the file name
to create the GCS bucket pod.
Then you create the client
to call the Vision API.
On this client, we call
the text detection method
and pass the GCS bucket pod from
where the file will be pulled.
At that point, we
have a resulting JSON
with all the detected text.
Since for this
example, we are only
interested in the
text description,
I created a list of all
the text descriptions
and returned it as is.
Back in our intent map, we
are taking the return value
and sending it as a
response to the user.
As you can imagine,
the possibilities
are endless with an
integration like this.
Once you have it working,
you can pretty much
change the Vision API methods
to identify labels, landmarks,
faces, and more.
You can also use
the same concept
and integrate with other
ML APIs, like NLP, vision,
translation, jobs, and
even your custom ML APIs
that you built through AutoML.
I cannot wait to hear from
you how you are applying this
integration.
Tell us all about your use
case in the comments below.
Today we learned how
to create a custom
Dialogflow front-end on App
Engine using Django framework
and integrated it with
Vision API on the back-end.
I hope to see you in the next
episode of Deconstructing
Chatbots.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]